[Music]
each year millions in new york city are
drawn to central parks manicured lawns
or
the high lines creative design but it's
the smaller
lesser-known community-run gardens that
may show the city's true personality the
best
there are more community gardens in the
big apple than anywhere else in the
country
and as christina ruffini found out
they're as diverse as the people who run
them
this is new york city cramped cluttered
plagued by loitering overcrowding
and the constant buzz of bees
i think it has the best part of new york
because you never know what's going to
happen next
tucked away in once unclaimed corners of
the concrete jungle
are actual jungles tended to by
volunteers like penny jones
who's been planting in this lower east
side plot for nearly 30 years
what makes you come back here year after
year and do all this for free
i don't have to go to the country on the
weekend i'm 10 minutes from my apartment
no traffic the traffic waits just
outside the gate
but inside there are bluebells and fish
and well calm why are places like this
important like why can't i just knock
this down and make some condos
for one thing the lungs of the city
we provide a huge amount of oxygen and
bring down the temperature
the gardens throw some serious shade
more than 550 covering a hundred acres
of some of the most valuable real estate
in the five boroughs
the city lets the gardeners use the land
for free in return
they must be open for the public but the
partnership
wasn't always so pleasant what did this
place look like in 73
it looked like a barren desert i mean
there was nothing here
donald loggins is one of the original
green gorillas
a militant group of gardeners recruited
by local activist liz christie to clean
up the neighborhoods
the insurgency started with seed
grenades balloons filled with flowers
and fertilizer
we'd go around in the evening and throw
them over the fences and
it worked their tactics soon escalated
taking over this plot that would
eventually become the city's first
official community garden we had
problems with people coming
into the space and trying to deal drugs
one guy
tried to rip off a branch from a tree we
chased him down the subway with
pitchforks
he never came back again he probably
didn't expect to get chased by
pitchforks in manhattan
probably not but it worked it kept them
away and as the plants grew
so did the concept all over the city
people began
tilling their blighted blocks you want
to get as much of the roof as possible
today the gardens are as diverse as the
neighborhoods they represent
every garden is different it's a
reflection of the neighborhood and their
needs and wants and wishes
for for they want to make new york
better
carlos martinez is the deputy director
of new york city's green thumb program
which helps provide seeds and support
for the otherwise self-funded gardens
if these weren't maintained by
volunteers would the city be able to
keep up gardens like this
it would be very difficult for the city
to maintain like so many gardens so
we really value all the bloodstream and
tears that all the our gardeners
put into this originally from columbia
martinez says the gardens are popular
with new new yorkers
looking to put down some roots many of
our immigrant gardeners
join a community garden because they
want to reflect of home
at tranquility farms in bedsky brooklyn
it's the forest cynthia which is the
plant of new york city inna mcpherson
brings a bit of her jamaican heritage to
this inner city soil
i always say my mom raised us in an
urban setting with rural sensibilities
she teaches local kids where the food
they see packaged and processed
actually comes from this is arugula and
shows them eggs from her brood of
chickens
which she insisted we hold how do i put
the chicken down
i don't want to stick her like this and
all right she says the gardens bring
value beyond plants and produce
i mean look what's going on in here
there's birds in here there are trees
nature abounds in here and you if you
have all these green spaces
you know how are you going to live
living without them is a constant fear
while many gardens are protected the
threat of development is
always there still the once dirt cover
disrupters have been embraced by their
communities
giving loggins more time to tend to his
thoughts
it's so nice to come here and just enjoy
yourself and realize
you know how green the city can be and
peaceful well some of the time
for cbs this morning saturday christina
raffini new york
you would think that people would really
love to have
i mean developers even to have a
community garden
in their neighborhood right that they
wouldn't fight it too much i think
they're thinking
money sometimes for developers i agree
with you it's beautiful the balance
yeah there's a balance to be found
though between the development and and
keeping some of these and people that
don't live in in the city like new york
don't realize
it is a nice little escape even if you
hear that siren just sitting in that
environment well back in the day
everybody had a backyard garden
you know so now we're getting back to it